so we've got a corn and avocado salsa  for your cocktail party so let's make a  great drink to match we're gonna make a  Negroni Negroni is a classic gin  cocktail made with Campari the flavor  here is very powerful which will balance  well with the fresh light flavors of our  salsa so we start a little ice in our  glass the equal parts Bombay Sapphire  Campari and sweet vermouth give a little  skirt garnish with orange  so it's a bold pairing the big flavor  Thunder groaning Mary's perfectly with  your light zesty salsa you just can't  beat it serve these two together and  your cocktail party is off to a great  start if you guys want more tips and  tricks subscribe to the Jiki Channel